here in the u.s to kentucky where there
was a high drama moment in louisville in
a courtroom when a former police
detective linked to the killing of
briana taylor testified in his own
defense brett hankinson called the death
of the young emergency medical
technician that would be brianna a
tragedy and he got emotional when he
described how the botched police raid
unfolded we should point out that
hankinson is not charged with killing
taylor but rather endangering her
neighbors
national correspondent jerica duncan has
been following the trial
is there anything brett that you feel
like you did wrong absolutely not
what were your feelings about this
entire incident
tragedy
it's something that didn't have to
happen former louisville metro police
detective brett hankinson defended
himself in a kentucky courtroom
wednesday
she didn't need to die that night
briana taylor's mother tamika palmer was
there but walked out after hankerson
made that comment she's done
investigators say his bullets didn't hit
anybody but after the raid the then
police chief said hankerson had blindly
fired his gun calling hankerson's
actions a shock to the conscience i felt
sincere empathy for them in march of
2020 police dressed in plain clothes
armed with a no knock warrant broke into
taylor's louisville apartment looking
for an alleged drug dealer but neither
taylor nor her boyfriend kenneth walker
who were inside were the targets of the
raid walker mistook the cops for
intruders and fired his gun once the
police returned fire shooting 32 times
walker spoke with gayle king about the
raid in october of 2020. i don't think i
ever heard so many gunshots like all the
same time i've never been to war but i
assume that's what wars probably sounds
like several times during testimony
hakusan became emotional as he talked
about sergeant jonathan mattingly
getting shot i knew sergeant mattingly
was down and i knew
i knew they were trying to get to him
and it appeared to me that
they were being executed with this rifle
it was a handgun that walker legally
owned mattingly survived or survived
rather and was one of the police
officers who fired shots that struck
taylor now the former sergeant who
retired from the force has been
promoting his new book what he calls the
truth about the raid mattingly has not
been in court for the trial hankerson
faces up to 15 years in prison if
convicted
he he calls it the truth he's promoting
it um i know you you saw the video where
he promotes it
um
he claims that a lot of things
were not accurate and that the media got
it wrong yeah but we'll you know we know
for a fact is a woman who was
killed was not the target and that
target the man they were looking for is
on probation he's not even serving any
time all because of
you know a drug raid i think a lot of
people have questions here on the one
hand higginson says he did nothing wrong
but on the other hand he says this was
an avoidable tragedy and i think people
might be confused as to why he's on
trial for endangering neighbors as
opposed to anything related to brianna's
death yeah the grand jury found that
because the police officers were shot at
with that one shot
that was a threat and that they acted
appropriately
so this is really i think in the eyes of
the the taylor family the only chance at
potential justice even though it is not
related directly this is the only
officer that was charged in connection
to this i know the officer is speaking
his truth and saying that you know it
didn't have to happen yeah i think that
yeah that was hard for the mom that's
what i was thinking that tamika palmer
sitting in that in that courtroom
listening to police officers say that
about her daughter i think she would
have loved to hear it shouldn't have
happened yeah yeah yeah just to turn the
phrase there would have made a big
difference definitely yeah
sad story all the way yesterday
thank you very much we know you keep
following